oh hi Maddie I have a question for you
do you like shopping do you want to go
shopping Maddie this is Maddie this is
my dog
we adopted him about four and a half
years ago he is a beautiful boy who
really needs a bath so thankfully this
is just a 3d video you can't actually
smell him yeah you are a smelly boy
today we're gonna be hanging out with
Maddie in 3d and if you guys have a
headset that is the best viewing
experience for this but again if you are
watching on YouTube how about doggy -
you guys can scroll around or move your
phone to get the full experience right
now I'm wondering Maddie do you want to
go shopping do you want to go to the pet
store let's go to them let's go to the
doggy mall come on let's go No you don't
want to go shopping
Maddie hates his harness usually he runs
around like crazy and tries to get away
from it but this is the cutest thing
ever he'll do a little jump to help me
put it on okay ready okay ready let's
get to this little leg ease up oh you're
beautiful boy Maggie likes floral I like
floral so I guess by proxy
so it's mad
matching leash this is a little dirty
maybe won't get you a new one today at
the pet store
oh I forgot my phone you love car rides
don't you bud
man I need to get a 3d carwash yep
stop good boy get in there car wash so
we're gonna go to the car wash first
because
I can't see out of my windows and then
we will continue on with Maddie's fun
day
that's definitely a car wash that is no
longer in service
wait there's a car wash next door look I
love things that happen like that this
is like a drive-through oh I know I do
you think we can go like McDonald's or
something we can get like a little
milkshake that sounds good
maybe go to Wendy's we can get a
smoothie I know this person's backing up
like a foot what are you doing do you
even know how to drive I'm gonna hit a
car I know seriously what is she doing
it okay
so I pick what I want what are the
chances you brought your wallet
cuz wait no I have it I have money Madi
I can't believe you didn't bring your
wallet I'm gonna just get a single wash
thank you we're doing it don't let me
see Bobo shuffle wait hold on I think
I'll be okay I haven't gone through one
of these car washes in so long
everything that I thought today was
gonna be
[Music]
I'm glad my car's letting me know that
there's danger present Wow howdy have
you heard me throw car wash before
[Music]
all right we're done at the car wash now
we're gonna go to the pet store to get
some toys for Maddy I'm also still
thinking about that drive-through we are
one of your favorite stores well there
are so many cute outfits here Maddy
let's go let's go see if there's
something here you might want so Maddy
here's the rule if you touch it for more
than two seconds it could be yours
that bone is too big for you okay do you
like Star Wars as much as mommy does
look he's so happy he's so happy
do you want like a little Chewbacca
outfit ready that's a little too big for
you over here okay over here oh my
goodness
come here look at this do you see this
this is something that you need you need
this for sure oh this is a nice vintage
little Star Wars shirt come here look
see this nice it's vintage vintage no
it's good Oh Maddie there's outfits over
here come on
look at this pig mm I don't think you
like that you're not a girl but you look
good in pink you have got to stop
pulling so hard
mommy is weak look at this oh this is
gonna look so nice on you this is poop
Factory Maddie okay this is not going
well so you don't like the poop factory
outfit Maddie jr. new harness let's go
get you a new harness well so I'm going
this way but well at this point I'm just
basically letting him do whatever he
wants which is usually what he does
anyway have you ever gone through hoop
before nope
guess we're not gonna do that today
either but she's little thank you soon
I think this might fit you oh my gosh
you're beautiful
maybe I did it wrong how do I do that
well it soothes it yeah
Oh handsome AF you're being a very good
boy there will be many treats in your
future mister many treats in your future
yeah I think this is good okay that
sweater for you
sweater should they have tape baskets
now do you want Christmas toy sit good
boy I'll get this for you okay look at
all these outfits for you okay let's go
find you some more things you're thirsty
buddy don't have don't have a bowl
there's a drink out of my hand we're
best buds
this is what we do keep drinking
good enough for now we're going to Wendy
so I'll get you a water to go you sure
the blanket oh you're new things that
you've got today but you're just can you
give mommy a kiss
No hey can't wait to get frosting can I
also do a birthday cake frosty sundae
can I get our water with no ice let me
get you a drink oh my goodness Maddy I
have something for you
sit what a good boy let's see what your
pillow your blanket I brought this out
for you
okay Maddy I'm gonna sit in your bed cuz
it's cold out here
do you like that I mean you're better do
you know what's in there do we get some
toys this is one of your first toys yes
how fun is this how fun sit lay down
good boy
do your little tricks for us and he's
off well I have a whole bag full of
other toys here but I feel like maybe we
have ourself a winner
[Music]
let me just take the tag off I have to
take the tag off all the rest of his
things or outfits and he's not gonna
like this Manny with dis you look very
dapper let's see what else we have for
you oh my goodness look at this I've got
you some balls to play with sit go get
it hey bring the ball over here so I can
juggle them oh go get it Matty go get
your toy he's making like a weird little
collection over there this is gonna look
so adorable on you Matty oh my goodness
it you're definitely gonna get a deep
this is gonna look really lovely this
looks like something that you can wear
to Paris be a real Parisian pup I am
unbelievably unable to control my
excitement about this you're beautiful
look how great you look this is such a
great look on you got your food
you still have your bandana on you look
handsome we gotta cook this up for you
Maddie's actually such a diva about his
food that I have to chop it up even
though it's soft food sit wait wait go
ahead
so obedient when there's food involved I
guess since he's having his dinner I'll
have mine Maddie can you believe that
Wendy's has birthday cake frosty some
day you can't have any yet for dessert
oh my gosh this should be illegal you're
eating the wrong way when you just have
seen your face eating good boy eat all
your food who do you think did you have
a good dinner don't have somewhere yeah
we spin it around for you so you don't
have to reach for it I know you okay put
a little bit in your in your bowl there
you go okay thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this video
and again thanks to our wonderful dear
sweet DJ mini Matt for being such a
great pup today and always I'll see you
guys in my next video bye say bye sit
sit me pop it's me Paul good boy I'll
give you a little more ice cream you're
playing at a tummyache now just like
mommy